what's going on guys new spider-man
coming tomorrow so be sure to subscribe
to get it I'll be doing a new round of
the action figure giveaway - so all
they're hyping up here is the spider
BOTS like one new thing that the suit
can do that we didn't know about
so those probably come out of the
gauntlets and we also learned a little
bit about the backstory of the MCU
version of the vulture so I'll explain
that too so this really is a stark tech
iron spider suit in everything but name
I know like the comic book suit looks
very different but it's basically the
suit built by Tony Stark
the spider BOTS themselves though came
from superior spider-man way back in
2013 they used to be the octobots so if
you didn't know superior spider-man was
appeared in the comics when the mind of
Otto Octavius Doctor Octopus took over
spider-man's body and he tried to be
good but he was kind of an so
it's an edgier version of spider-man a
lot of people didn't like the title so
Peter Parker came back in short order
but the big thing during his run is as
they set up parker industries which is
kind of like the spider-man version of
Stark Industries so that's just a comic
book thing obviously Peter Parker's at
high school but it's just more evidence
that they're pulling from all over the
comics to do spider-man stuff so there
is a little bit of Doctor Octopus in the
movie in spirit it's not an actual body
and I do I think they'll totally get to
sinister 6 eventually they're capable of
doing a whole bunch of things they're
tiny robots basically so they have
cameras so they can feed information
into the lenses so he can see things
remotely they can activate technology
they can tap into communication so he
can use them to listen in on police or
in the case of spider-man homecoming
listen in on villains
and they're also capable of giving him a
whole bunch of sensory information about
the weaknesses and stats of the people
that he's fighting so we have yet to see
it like I don't know if it's actually
going to happen in the movie but we
might see a version of an Iron Man
heads-up display for spider-man but I
don't know if they'd actually put them
inside the helmet I know they really
want you to think about Iron Man when
you think about this version of
spider-man but I haven't seen a version
of spider-man in the comics that I can
remember where they actually went inside
the mask heads-up display style so I
don't expect them to do that the
let me know do you actually want them to
do something like that like Iron Man
style for spider-man it would be kind of
weird but I guess I could roll with it
the cool new thing about the vultures
back story we learned the Adrian Toomes
version is that he is the original
version of the vulture from the comics
but in the MCU he's somebody who cleans
up after big superhero battles to find
cool toys that he gives to the tinkerer
did they turn into new technology so
that's how we get to his flight suit
built out of leftover our tech
after the invasion in the first Avengers
movie but the producers went on to say
that they are giving him the classic
Adrian Toomes origin story his business
partner cut him out of his business so
he is forced to turn to crime so in the
MCU
that's Tony Stark he steals a contract
from him because he's an evil version of
Tony Stark kind of like Justin Hammer
albeit in a different way so when Tony
Stark steals a business contract out
from under him he goes berserk so he is
after Tony Stark in addition to a bunch
of other things going on in the movie so
now you see the significance of the
Avengers tower there's still a lot of
stark tech left in there and they might
even have a big action set piece at the
stark Expo like we had an Iron Man 2
maybe they can make it cool again that
movie was pretty cool Iron Man 2 had a
lot of fun things in it but it was kind
of a mess the other big things are
hyping up is one of the big action set
pieces with the vulture vs. spider-man
in his old version of the costume so
this looks like it takes place way
before the events of Civil War before he
gets the stark tech suit and gets his
ass handed to him with this moment in
the trailer where he's like lying on the
beach which it almost looks like he's at
Coney Island because there's a big
ferris wheel in the back so this is
still local to New York
and like the big action set piece at the
end that might be the Staten Island
Ferry so it's almost like he's going all
over New York City we have yet to see
anything from Brooklyn though no we're
all wondering about Captain America but
if he shows up in the movie I would be
blown away
he showed up in Brooklyn because he's a
wanted fugitive so it'd be like the
stupidest thing ever for him to hang out
so what it looks like is happening is
with each of these new trailers that we
get remember the movie is not coming out
till July so there's going to be a bunch
more trailers is we're sort of unlocking
new abilities that the suit
that we don't know about so all this
stuff was in the suit when we were in
civil war he just didn't know about it
because it was brand new so part of the
fun of the movie is him sitting with Ned
Leeds here trying to unlock the other
abilities of the suit that's what this
scene is all about is then trying to
hack into the suit to see what's going
on like what else can it do that I don't
know about yet so let me know in the
comments what other abilities do you
actually think that the suit has that we
don't know about that they'll save for
later trailers and there's probably a
whole bunch of the movie that they'll
save for the final trailer but I
wouldn't be surprised if at some point
in the movie he gets even more upgrades
from Tony Stark or something just to add
to the suit a little bit although
because this is the first big Spider Man
solo movie I think the suit will look
like this for a long time so if we get
to infinity war and he gets a new
version of the suit the color scheme and
the design will stay mostly the same
it'll just get a lot of hidden Iron Man
tech it'll manifest whenever he needs it
like spider bot style like you wouldn't
know those existed it would just look
like a normal cloth Spider Man suit
unless he activated it so what's going
to happen next is is I have new Game of
Thrones that's long overdue I'll post
that but let me know in the comments
what other Spider Man what are the
Marvel videos you want me to do this
week there's so much going on there
might even be some more Justice League's
at all post later so I'll try to get to
that as fast as possible while you wait
for that you can click here for brand
new guardians of the galaxy and you can
click here for all the Justice League's
that I posted this weekend thank you so
much for watching let's high-five I will
see you guys in the next video